Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. just rejoice at that news and congratulate our forces and the marines rejoice so uh dominic that was mrs satcher um yeah obviously well i mean maybe you thought it was mrs satcher because it was so unerringly accurate that was actually me it was me all along possibly leon leeson tom no um you're just being jealous so yeah that was mrs satcher responding to the news that south georgia had fallen to the task force um yes and my memory of that is that uh she's on the steps of downing street and john not is with her looking incredibly embarrassed
感谢您收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。只需为这一消息欢呼，并向我们的军队和海军陆战队表示祝贺……呃，多米尼克，那是撒切尔夫人——嗯，很明显，呃，我的意思是，也许你以为那是撒切尔夫人，因为她语气那么准确无误，其实那其实是我，一直以来都是我，可能是利昂·里森·汤姆，不，呃，你只是在嫉妒。所以，是的，那是撒切尔夫人对南乔治亚岛被特遣舰队攻陷这一消息的回应。是的，我对此的记忆是，呃，她站在唐宁街的台阶上，约翰·诺特和她在一起，看起来极其尴尬。
by this kind of exultant tub thumping. Actually, no, because what actually happens, Tom, you're right that John Nott does look embarrassed at that point, but it's very weird because they come out and she says, ladies and gentlemen, the Secretary of State for Defence has some very good news, which I think he'd like to share with you. And he's sort of standing there like a child who's been asked to perform. And he looks incredibly miserable. I mean, he just looks fantastically unhappy. And he reads this statement, the White Ensign flies over South Georgia, God save the Queen.
对这种兴高采烈、大肆吹嘘的做派感到尴尬。其实不然，因为实际情况是，汤姆，你说的对，约翰·诺特在那时确实看起来很尴尬，但非常诡异的是，他们走出来，她说：“女士们先生们，国防大臣有好消息要宣布，我想他很愿意与大家分享。”而他站在那里，就像一个被叫上去表演的孩子。他看起来极其沮丧。我的意思是，他看起来简直倒霉透顶。他宣读了这份声明：“白船旗飘扬在南乔治亚岛上空，上帝保佑女王。”
And she wasn't going to say anything. And then they turned to go in and the newspaper people shouted questions. And she says then, just rejoice at that news. So actually, not, I don't know, his demeanor is just so lugubrious. But that final rejoice, she kind of pops back out of the door, doesn't she? Yes, she does. Yeah. It's a sort of admonition to the press, isn't it? Yeah.
她本来没打算说什么。然后他们转身准备进去，记者们大声喊着提问。于是她接着说：“只需为那一消息欢呼。”所以实际上，诺特——我不知道，他的神情就是那么阴郁。但最后那句“欢呼”，她又从门后探出头来了，对吧？是的，确实如此。是对媒体的一种告诫，对吧？
And I suppose that it's remembered because it captures something about her role in the war, that increasingly she is identified both by supporters of the war and opponents of it as towards the war is channeled by an episode that happens in the wake of South Georgia, which is the sinking of an Argentine troop ship called the Belgrano. Yeah. So it's about the point of South Georgia where she's told people to rejoice. You know, basically, there's been virtually no loss of life. So one Argentine soldier was killed in the capture of the islands. But since then, certainly nobody from Britain has died. And there's been no large-scale loss of life at all. The public in Britain are delighted by South Georgia.
我想人们之所以记住这件事，是因为它捕捉到了她在战争中的某种角色：支持战争的人和反对战争的人都越来越将她与战争联系在一起，而这种情绪是通过南乔治亚岛事件之后发生的一件事被引导出来的，那件事就是阿根廷的一艘运兵船“贝尔格拉诺”号被击沉。是的。所以，这是在南乔治亚岛事件之后，她告诉人们去欢呼。你知道的，基本上，当时几乎没有人员伤亡。在夺取岛屿的过程中，只有一名阿根廷士兵丧生。但自那以后，英国方面肯定还没有人死亡。而且根本没有发生大规模的伤亡。英国公众对南乔治亚岛的结果欣喜若狂。
And the press are absolutely beside themselves. We'll come to the press in a bit. And Mrs. Thatcher is increasingly playing this Churchillian role. Her rhetoric is full of allusions to Kipling. And she says that Britain has found its role to fight for liberty and all this stuff. But so far it is like a kind of – It's a game.
媒体也完全陷入了狂热。我们一会儿再谈媒体。撒切尔夫人越来越扮演起丘吉尔式的角色。她的言论中充满了对吉卜林的典故引用。她说英国已经找到了为自由而战的角色以及诸如此类的话。但到目前为止，这就像是一种——这就像是一场游戏。
It's bloodless. It's like a computer game or a TV drama or something. Or it's a role-playing game. A role-playing game, yeah. Everybody is playing the part of – exactly. And then there is the mission that um i know you you wanted to talk about earlier which is uh britain has sent vulcan bombers to bomb the um the the airstrip in in the fulcrum islands to stop the argentines getting um supplies and that's the one where
这是不流血的。它就像是一个电脑游戏、一幕电视剧之类的。或者说它是一个角色扮演游戏。一个角色扮演游戏，是的。每个人都在扮演……完全是这样。然后就是那个任务，呃，我知道你之前想谈的，就是呃——英国派遣了“火神”轰炸机去轰炸富克兰群岛上的那个——那个飞机跑道，以阻止阿根廷人获得补给。就是那个……
they refuel it in midair they refuel in midair which is i still don't quite understand how that works your brother's podcast would be able to explain. They would spend entire episodes discussing refueling valves or something. But they do it. But in our podcast, we don't go in for that malarkey at all. But they do it. And this is seen as this tremendous feat, even though they don't manage to knock out the airfield completely. But then the day after that, I think pretty much, it's a Sunday.
他们在空中加油。他们在空中加油，说实话我还是不太明白那是怎么运作的。你兄弟的播客肯定能解释清楚。他们会花上整整几集来讨论加油阀之类的事情。但他们确实做到了。而在我们的播客里，我们才不搞那一套胡闹呢。不过他们确实这么做了。这被视为一项了不起的壮举，尽管他们并没有完全摧毁那个机场。但就在那之后的第二天，我记得差不多就是那天，是个星期日。
She's in Chequers. The defense chiefs arrive. They say they need to talk to her urgently and they basically say we've had a request from the commander of the task force in the south atlantic which is steaming south um there are two argentine ships in particular that have been shadowing the task force that um they've alarmed about One they've already talked about, which is the 25th of May. And the other one is named after a hero of the Argentine War of Independence.
她在契克斯庄园。国防高官们赶到了。他们说需要紧急与她谈谈，基本上是说他们收到了正向南航行的南大西洋特遣舰队指挥官的请求——有两艘阿根廷军舰一直在尾随特遣舰队，这让他们感到警惕。其中一艘他们已经讨论过了，就是“五月二十五日”号。另一艘则是以阿根廷独立战争的一位英雄命名的。
He was called General Belgrano. And the General Belgrano is this sort of aging cruiser with more than a thousand men on board. And the British commanders would like permission to sink the Belgrano. Now, this is the single most controversial episode of the war. One of the most controversial episodes of Mrs. Thatcher's whole career. If you've seen the film, The Iron Lady with Meryl Streep, you will remember that she shouts,
他叫贝尔格拉诺将军。而“贝尔格拉诺将军”号是一艘老旧的巡洋舰，船上有上千名官兵。英国指挥官们希望获得击沉“贝尔格拉诺”号的许可。现在，这是这场战争中最具争议的事件，也是撒切尔夫人整个职业生涯中最具争议的事件之一。如果你看过梅丽尔·斯特里普主演的电影《铁娘子》，你就会记得她大喊：
sink it. And Dominic, what makes this controversial is that the British have said that they're setting up an exclusion zone a total exclusion zone that's 200 miles around the falklands and that that any argentine ship found within that will be shot will be sunk and attacked yeah but this does not mean that they're committed to not attack ships outside the exclusion zone yes often often right, right. So often, if you loiter, Tom, as I do every day on the Guardian website, reading the comments underneath articles, people will often say, ah, it wasn't in the exclusion zone,
击沉它。多米尼克，这件事之所以具有争议，是因为英国人曾宣布他们将设立一个禁区——一个全面禁区，即福克兰群岛周围200英里的范围——任何在该范围内被发现的阿根廷船只都将被开火、被击沉并遭到攻击。是的，但这并不意味着他们承诺不会攻击禁区之外的船只。是的，经常，总是这样，对吧。所以经常，如果你闲逛，汤姆，就像我每天在《卫报》网站上阅读文章下方的评论一样，人们经常会说，啊，它当时不在禁区内，
therefore it shouldn't have been. It was illegal to attack it. It was a war crime and stuff. Now, that's completely wrong. When the British said there was a total exclusion zone around the Falklands, they explicitly said, if you're an Argentine ship ship going 210 miles or 220 miles beyond the falklands does not get you off the hook if you're a danger to their forces
因此它本不该被攻击。攻击它是非法的，是战争罪，诸如此类。现在，这完全是错误的。当英国人说福克兰群岛周围有全面禁区时，他们明确表示：如果你是一艘阿根廷船只，驶到福克兰群岛外210英里或220英里的地方，并不能让你脱离险境，如果你对他们的部队构成了危险，
they will sink you wherever what's the point of the total exclusion zone if they're still going to attack ships outside it the exclusion zone is basically saying especially for other ships don't come into the exclusion zone okay so it's not's not just targeted at Argentines. This is a designated kind of theater of war, basically. I mean, I know there'll be people who are absolute experts on this sort of stuff, listen to this and think that it's not right, blah,
他们会在任何地方击沉你。如果他们还是要攻击禁区外的船只，那设立全面禁区还有什么意义？设立禁区基本上是为了说明——特别是对其他船只而言——不要进入禁区。好吧，所以它不仅仅是针对阿根廷人的。这基本上是一个指定的战争区域。我的意思是，我知道会有人对此类事情绝对精通的人，听了这话会觉得不对劲，巴拉巴拉巴拉。但是，基本上这就好比是在说：
blah, blah. But, but basically this is sort of saying, this is the battlefield. Everybody else stay out. And if any Argentine ship in this area, we will sink you.
这就是战场。其他人统统避开。这个区域内的任何阿根廷船只，我们都会将其击沉。
But that doesn't mean. But we might still sink you if you're outside it. Yeah. Because you're a threat to our ships. you've invaded our islands so what's happening is the belgrano is this cruiser it's it's supported by destroyers i mean it's not there on a kind of it hasn't been rented for a pleasure outing it's there for a good reason you know to attack the task force the argentine commander who is rear admiral ayara he has a plan with a sort of pincer movement he has the vento sink into my in the north and the Belgrano in the south.
但这并不意味着：如果你在禁区外，我们可能还是会击沉你。是的。因为你对我们的船只有威胁。你们入侵了我们的岛屿。所以发生的情况是，“贝尔格拉诺”号这艘巡洋舰，它有驱逐舰护航——我的意思是，它去那里可不是进行某种观光的，它不是为了游玩而出租的，它去那儿是有充分理由的，你知道的，是为了攻击特遣舰队。阿根廷指挥官、海军少将阿亚拉有一个钳形攻势的计划，他让“五月二十五日”号在北部，而“贝尔格拉诺”号在南部。
And between them, they will target Britain's aircraft carriers. Because the aircraft carriers, if the aircraft carriers go down, then basically the task force is sunk. Pretty much, I think. You need at least one aircraft carrier, ideally two, to give you the air cover and stuff. Because where else are your planes going to take off from? So Admiral Woodward, who's in charge of the task force, says to Mrs. Thatcher,
他们两面夹击，将目标对准英国的航空母舰。因为航空母舰一旦被击沉，那么基本上特遣舰队就被消灭了。差不多是这样，我认为。你需要至少一艘航空母舰，最好是两艘，来提供空中掩护之类。因为你的飞机还能从哪里起飞呢？所以负责特遣舰队的伍德沃德海军少将对撒切尔夫人说：
we'd like to attack the Belgrano police. It's outside because you have to ask permission. This is the thing, if it's outside the exclusion zone. So when he asked permission, he doesn't ask permission thinking there's any possibility she will say no. I mean, any prime minister, I think, by and large, would say yes. Because, counterfactual, she says no and the Belgrano then sinks the aircraft carrier. Right, and then she's damned for all eternity in British reputation.
我们想攻击“贝尔格拉诺”号，请批准。因为它在外面，所以你必须请求批准。就是这样，如果它在禁区之外的话。所以当他请求批准时，他并没有觉得她有任何可能说“不”。我的意思是，任何首相，我想，大体上都会说“愿意的”。因为，假设反过来，她说“不”，然后“贝尔格拉诺”号击沉了航空母舰。没错，那她在英国的声誉将遗臭万年。
It takes her and her ministers 20 minutes to say yes. It's just a no-brainer for them. Now, the complicated thing is this. The Belgrano looks like it's sailing towards the fleet, but by the time the order then gets to Admiral Wood woodward the belgrano has changed its course so what it's doing is zigzagging and the argentines had a plan for the attack but but in the small hours of sunday morning the weather has changed and the captain of the belgrano his man called hector bonzo he is told head back towards the mainland and await further orders for the time being.
她和她的部长们花了20分钟才说“行”。这对他们来说根本不用动脑子。现在，复杂的情况是这样的。“贝尔格拉诺”号看起来正朝着舰队驶去，但当命令传达到伍德沃德海军少将时，“贝尔格拉诺”号已经改变了航向。它在做之字形机动，阿根廷人原本有一个进攻计划，但在周日凌晨，天气变了，“贝尔格拉诺”号的舰长——一个叫赫克托·邦佐的人——接到命令：掉头开回本土，暂时听候进一步指示。
So don't attack immediately. He's not told, I mean, obviously, this doesn't mean never attack. It just means hold your horses. So when the British submarine, the Conqueror, which has been told to sink the Belgrano, when it sees the Belgrano, the direction in which it's sailing is irrelevant to them.
所以不要立即进攻。他得到的命令并不是说——当然，这并不意味着永远不进攻。这只是意味着暂且按兵不动。所以当英国潜艇“征服者”号（奉命击沉“贝尔格拉诺”号）发现“贝尔格拉诺”号时，它航行的方向对潜艇来说并不重要。
So the captain just basically tracks the Belgrano for two hours. He twice almost has it. doesn't quite get it but then at 357 i think it is in the afternoon um belgrano is in his sights conqueror opens fire two massive hits um probably about 200 people are killed immediately by the kind of fireball ripping through the corridors the belgrano in total 323 argentine sailors and or servicemen were killed a third of them were conscripts you have very young men more than 700 of them survive on these life rafts so if you've ever seen the photo the belgrano sinking it's actually the life rafts which are kind of orange yeah that are in the the foreground and actually with that the the Argentine admirals say, oh, the plan is destroyed.
所以舰长基本上就追踪了“贝尔格拉诺”号两个小时。他有两次差点就锁定它了，没能完全咬住。但随后大约在下午3点57分，“贝尔格拉诺”号进入了他的视线，“征服者”号开火了，两次重创。大约有200人可能在火球撕裂“贝尔格拉诺”号走廊的瞬间当场丧生。总共有323名阿根廷水兵和/或军人丧生，其中三分之一是征召兵。有非常年轻的士兵，其中700多人生存下来，坐在这些救生筏上。所以如果你看过“贝尔格拉诺”号沉没的照片，其实前景中那些呈橙色的正是救生筏。是的，随着这一事件，阿根廷海军将领们说：“哦，计划破产了。回港吧。”
Go back to port. So the rest of their fleet are knocked out by this one act of sinking the Bolgrano. So militarily, it's very successful. Yeah. I mean, militarily, there's absolutely no debate about it. But in human terms, as you say, 323 men are killed. And so, I mean, I suppose globally, suddenly this is no longer a kind of opera buffet. Right. Comic, carry on up the Khyber escapade.
于是他们舰队的其余部分因为击沉“贝尔格拉诺”号这一行动而被排除在外。因此从军事上讲，这是非常成功的。是的。我的意思是，从军事角度来看，这毫无争议。但从人道主义角度来说，正如你所说，有323人丧生。所以，我的意思是，在全球范围内，这突然之间不再是一场轻歌剧了。没错。不再是像喜剧电影《奔向凯伯山口》那样的冒险了。
Suddenly people are dying very horribly. And I think it also seems it's the fact that the major casualties are inflicted by the British, who suddenly seem like the bully. NATO bullies. The NATO bullies against the sort of plucky South Americans. Yes. That's how it plays. Okay, so that plays out internationally. And to a degree, it has that impact in Britain as well.
突然之间，人们开始以极其可怕的方式死去。而且我认为这也显得——主要的伤亡是由英国人造成的，英国人突然看起来像是恶棍。北约恶棍。北约恶棍对阵勇敢无畏的南美洲人。是的。事情就是这样发酵的。好吧，所以这在国际上产生了影响。在某种程度上，它在英国也产生了这种影响。
So it serves to confirm people who are opposed to the war, absolutely in their conviction that this is deeply immoral. And I think there's a woman who orders it, Tom, who signs it off. I mean, it's not her idea. It comes to her for the sign-off. And the fact that it's a woman who does it, people sort of say, how could a woman of all people, how ghastly, this dreadful woman, you know, who's presided over unemployment, et cetera, et cetera.
因此，它坚定那些反对战争的人的信念，让他们确信这场战争极其不道德。而且我想，下达这个命令、签字批准的是个女人，汤姆。我的意思是，这并不是她的主意。命令送到她这里来签字。而且执行这件事的是个女人，人们就会说：怎么会有这样的女人，太可怕了，这个可怕的女人，你知道的，她造成了失业等等等等。
So there's all that stuff. But there are also conspiracy theories, of course, about the sinking of the Belgrano. So the most famous one is the one propounded by the Labour MP, Tam Dayal. And he says, the Peruvians had cooked up a peace proposal. And Mrs. Thatcher knew of the peace proposal. And she deliberately ordered the sinking of the Belgrano in order to destroy any chance for peace because she craved war. And this is just, I mean, I'll pin my colors to the mast.
所以有所有这些言论。当然，关于击沉“贝尔格拉诺”号也有阴谋论。其中最著名的一个是由工党议员塔姆·戴利提出的。他说，秘鲁人当时炮制了一项和平提议。而撒切尔夫人知晓这个和平提议。为了毁掉任何和平的可能，她故意下令击沉“贝尔格拉诺”号，因为她渴望战争。这简直是——我的意思是，我表明我的立场。
It's utter, utter nonsense. It wasn't her idea to attack the Belgrano. The request came from below, from the Navy. She didn't know about the Peruvian peace proposal. And what's really interesting is what the Argentines themselves think about the Bacchina. So this is the aspect that you never see in the British sort of the sort of more self-flagellating British commentary about this. So the guy who was running the operation, Rear Admiral Ayala, he basically, he told the historian Martin Middlebrook, he said, we knew perfectly well the entire South Atlantic was an operational theater
这完全、彻底是无稽之谈。攻击“贝尔格拉诺”号不是她的主意。请求来自底层，来自海军。她根本不知道秘鲁的和平提议。真正有趣的是阿根廷人自己对“贝尔格拉诺”号事件的看法。这是你在英国那种带有自我鞭笞色彩的评论中永远看不到的一个方面。所以当时负责这次行动的海军少将阿亚拉，他基本上——他告诉历史学家马丁·米德尔布鲁克说：我们非常清楚整个南大西洋对双方来说都是一个作战剧场。
for both sides. We, as professionals, said it was just too bad that we lost the bug runner. The captain of the ship himself, Hector Bonzo, he said there was absolutely nothing wrong with the British attacking us. It was what we expected. It was completely reasonable. And there was an amazing thing I found, which i don't think had been written about before um in 2005 an argentine newspaper referred to the belgara sinking the belgorno offhand as a war crime and the former head of the argentine navy wrote a letter of
我们作为专业人士，认为丢掉“贝尔格拉诺”号只能怪我们自己倒霉。舰长赫克托·邦佐本人也表示，英国人攻击我们完全没有问题。这是我们预料之中的。这是完全合理的。我发现了一件令人惊叹的事情，我想以前没有人写过——在2005年，一家阿根廷报纸顺便将击沉“贝尔格拉诺”号称为战争罪，阿根廷海军前司令写了一封投诉信给这家报纸，显然是用西班牙语写的——
complaint to the newspaper obviously in spanish um and he's which which read as follows he said it was not a war crime, but a combat action. The Belgrano and the other ships were a threat and a danger to the British. It was not a violation of international law. It was an act of war. So I don't think there's actually, the funny thing about the Belgrano controversy
信的内容如下：他说这不是战争罪，而是一次战斗行动。“贝尔格拉诺”号和其他军舰对英国构成了威胁和危险。这并不违反国际法。这是一次战争行为。所以我认为实际上没有什么——关于“贝尔格拉诺”号争议有趣的地方在于，我实际上真的认为这没有什么太大的争议。好吧，多米尼克，既然如此，问题就来了：为什么它会引发这么大的争议？我要向你提出的是，之所以它如此具有争议，原因之一是英国的小报《太阳报》用了一个可以说是英国新闻史上最臭名昭著的头条来报道它，那就是“抓到了”（Gotcha）。
is I don't actually really think there's any great debate about it. Okay, well, Dominic, so in which case, the question then rises, why is it so controversial? And I would put it to you that one of the reasons why it's so controversial is that it was greeted by a British tabloid, The Sun, with what is probably the most notorious headline in the entire history of the British press, which was gotcha. Our lads sink gunboat and whole cruiser. The Navy had the arges on their knees last night after a devastating double punch wallop wallop etc etc and even they even they the sun become embarrassed about this
我们的小伙子击沉了炮艇和整艘巡洋舰。昨晚在经历了一次毁灭性的组合拳痛击之后，海军把阿根廷人打得跪地求饶，狠狠痛击，等等等等。甚至连他们——连《太阳报》自己也对此感到尴尬，嗯，他们改了，他们改了头条，是的。但本质上，正如一贯发生的那样——正如我们在脱欧时所看到的——双方的媒体报道都加深了各自的成见。
and well they changed it they changed they changed the headline yeah but essentially the press coverage on both sides as always tends to happen as we saw with brexit entrenches opinions yeah Yeah, of course. Knowing what the other side think kind of encourages editors on both sides to kind of go further and further and further. And this definitely happened with the Falklands. So The Sun, which had only recently overtaken The Mirror in the late 70s to become the best selling newspaper in Britain, Rupert Murdoch's paper, sort of populist, very pro-Thatcher,
是的，当然。了解对方的想法某种程度上会鼓励双方的编辑越走越远。福克兰群岛战争期间绝对发生了这种情况。所以《太阳报》在7年代末刚刚超越《镜报》，成为英国销量最大的报纸。这是鲁珀特·默多克的报纸，属于民粹主义、非常支持撒切尔、保守、极度爱国。
conservative, ultra patriotic. paper in britain rupert murdoch's paper sort of populist very pro-thatcher conservative ultra patriotic um so for our overseas listeners i mean the sun played an absolutely gigantic part in the kind of national imagination in the 80s um loved and loathed in equal measure um what is it about 12 million readers or something just enormous readers readership. And the Sun, right from the beginning, embraced the war with absolutely wholehearted enthusiasm. Can I read again a top historian, namely yourself, on this? So you describe, I think, was it the news editor or something, who's been on holiday when the Falcons warped. And he comes back to the Sun office and he finds the news editor
英国的报纸，鲁珀特·默多克的报纸，属于民粹主义、非常支持撒切尔、保守、极度爱国。所以对于我们海外的听众来说，我的意思是，《太阳报》在80年代的国家想象中扮演了极其巨大的角色，爱恨交织，大约有1200万读者左右，读者群体非常庞大。从一开始，《太阳报》就以满腔的热情投入到这场战争中。我能再读一段一位顶级历史学家——也就是你自己——对此的描述吗？你描述的，我想，是新闻编辑还是谁，在福克兰群岛战争爆发时正在度假。他回到《太阳报》办公室，发现新闻编辑
wearing a naval officer's cap and insisted on being called commander while a giant map of the south atlantic had been pinned up beneath a newly installed portrait of sir winston churchill yeah so they go full in and this is famously parodied by private eye satirical magazine yeah that the headline is kill an rg and win a metro yeah but i mean that's not it's hard to distinguish that from because kelvin mckenzie the editor of the sun famously when he saw the parody he said that's such a brilliant idea why didn't we think of that because they do all kinds of so they run again and again the same headline during the peace negotiations which is stick it
戴着海军军官帽，坚持让人称呼他为“指挥官”，而在刚安装好的温斯顿·丘吉尔爵士的肖像下方，挂着一张巨大的南大西洋地图。是的，他们全力以赴。讽刺杂志《Private Eye》对此进行了著名的讽刺：头条是“杀个阿根廷人，赢一辆莫里斯微型车”。我的意思是从中很难区分……因为《太阳报》的主编凯尔文·麦肯齐在看到这个讽刺时，曾有一句名言说：“这主意太棒了，我们怎么没想到呢？”因为他们做了各种各样的举动——在和平谈判期间，他们一遍又一遍地使用同一个头条，那就是“把这塞回你们的军政府去”。
up your hunter um they like it so much they make T-shirts, the Sun readers, sensational T-shirts, they call them, that people can write in and get these T-shirts. They run a column where you can send in anti-Argentine jokes. So the column invites you to give those damn arges a whole lot of bargy by sending in the best anti-Argentine, and which they will reward you with a tin of non-Argentine corned beef they do various stunts
他们太喜欢这个了，以至于还制作了T恤。读《太阳报》的读者们制作了耸人听闻的T恤，他们称之为耸人听闻的T恤，人们可以写信索取这些T恤。他们开设了一个专栏，你可以在里面发送反阿根廷的笑话。专栏邀请你通过发送最佳的反阿根廷言论，来给那些该死的阿根廷人找点麻烦，他们会用一罐非阿根廷产的咸牛肉作为奖励。他们还搞了各种噱头。
so something that is very controversial as well as the gotcha they sponsor a missile and they get they write stick it up your hunter on the missile. And the big story is saying, to Galtieri's gauchos with love from the sun.
所以有一件非常有争议的事情，除了“抓到了”那个头条，他们还资助了一枚导弹，并在导弹上写着“把这塞回你们的军政府去”。主要的报道是：“带着《太阳报》的爱，献给加尔铁里的高乔人。”
All this sort of stuff. And don't they also donate massive portraits of... Page three models. Topless models. Page three models. They airlift them. They airlift them to Ascension Island so that they can go on. they airlift them they airlift them to ascension island so that they can go on they airlift them so they airlift them out to the fleet so the task force will have
所有这些类似的事情。而且他们还捐赠了大量的……第三版女郎的巨幅画像。上装全裸的女郎。第三版女郎。他们用空运把她们空运到阿森松岛，好让她们能够继续。他们用空运把她们空运到阿森松岛，好让她们能够继续。他们把她们空运到舰队，这样特遣舰队在途中就有东西可看了。
something to look at when they're when they're en route so there's a whole series of i mean they absolutely you know they absolutely go for it in terms of these sort of jingoistic stunts which as you say leaves some people absolutely appalled and And funnily enough, The Sun's readership actually declines. But The Sun also, it accuses, it absolutely, unrepentantly accuses critics of the war being traitors. I mean, its big rival, The Daily Star, famously commissioned a lawyer to see if Tony Benn could be prosecuted for treason for opposing the war um they accuse the daily mirror of being traitors what is it but treason they say in this
所以有一系列——我的意思是，他们绝对——在这些沙文主义的噱头方面，他们真的是全力以赴，正如你所说，这让一些人感到彻底震惊。说来也巧，《太阳报》的读者群实际上有所下降。但《太阳报》也毫不悔改地指责战争的批评者是叛徒。我的意思是，它的最大竞争对手《每日星报》曾委托一名律师，看托尼·本是否因反对战争而被以叛国罪起诉。他们指控《每日镜报》是叛徒。除了叛国还能是什么？他们在这一篇巨大的社论中说。他们真正穷追猛打的机构是BBC。
huge editorial the organization that they really go after is the bbc so you yeah you've been guilty of this the british broadcasting corporation yes but but um not calling them our troops. After the Belgrano, is it on Newsnight, Peter Snow, father of Dan, refers to the British. Can we trust the British? And this generates blowback, doesn't it? Massive. So this is on Newsnight. He says, we know that the Argentines are not telling us the truth but we can't be sure about the british will and when he does the the bbc deluge with complaints not least from conservative backbenchers saying how dare you call us the british and imply that we have propaganda exactly exactly so they get the
所以，你——你曾为此感到内疚，英国广播公司（BBC）。是的，但是，呃——没有称呼我们的军队为“我们的军队”。在“贝尔格拉诺”号事件之后，是在《新闻之夜》（Newsnight）节目中，丹·斯诺的父亲彼得·斯诺提到英国人时说：“我们能信任英国人吗？”这引发了强烈的反弹，不是吗？非常强烈。所以在《新闻之夜》节目中，他说：“我们知道阿根廷人没有对我们说实话，但我们不能确定英国人的意志。”当他这么说时，BBC收到了大量的投诉，其中不乏来自保守党后座议员的投诉，他们说：“你们怎么敢称我们为‘英国人’，并暗示我们是在搞宣传？”
most you know sort of intense abuse but then they also do a panorama um a sort of anti additional panorama which is this big sort of current affairs flagship news program where they sort of look at the case against war they interview people who they have a sort of report from buenos aires they have interviews with with dissenting mps like tory backbenchers who had fought in world war ii and don't think the war is a good idea and this gets a colossal amount of flack uh dennis thatcher basically says you know i'll never trust the bbc again they're pinkos i mean not that he ever did in the first place no i think it's fair to say you know the daily express has a big thing about tratorama and so obviously the sinking of the belgrano amplifies this debate but then what further sharpens it is the sinking of a british ship
完全如此，完全如此。所以他们遭到了最强烈、最猛烈的辱骂。但随后他们还制作了一期《全景》（Panorama）节目——一期反战性质的《全景》节目，这是一个大型的时事旗舰新闻节目，他们在节目中探讨反对战争的理由，采访他们派往布宜诺斯艾利斯的记者，采访持不同政见的议员，比如曾参加过第二次世界大战、认为战争不是个好主意的保守党后座议员。这引发了铺天盖地的批评。丹尼斯·撒切尔基本上说：“你知道的，我再也不会信任BBC了，他们都是左翼分子。”虽然他本来也没信任过。不，我认为可以公平地说，你知道的，《每日快报》曾大肆报道“叛徒全景”（Traitorama）。因此，显然“贝尔格拉诺”号的沉没放大了这场争论，但接下来让争论进一步白热化的，是一艘英国军舰的沉没。
um hms sheffield and what one of the kind of one of the overriding memories i think for everybody who lived through the falklands war and watched it on british tv was the lugubrious tones of um ian mcdonald who was the ministry of defense spokesman so so i've got it here. And he announced it as though he was announcing the cricket score. I don't think you'll be able to do it as boringly as he did it, Tom. In the course of its duties within the total exclusion zone, HMS Sheffield, a Type 42 destroyer, was attacked and hit late this afternoon by an Argentine missile. And it was that tension, the contrast between the absolute bled of emotion and the thought of how many lives had been lost
英国皇家海军“谢菲尔德”号。经历过福克兰群岛战争并在英国电视上观看过它的人，心中挥之不去的记忆之一，就是国防部发言人伊恩·麦克纳尔多那阴郁的语调。我有他的原话。他宣布这个消息的语气，就像是在宣布板球比分一样。我想你没法像他那样讲得那么无聊，汤姆。“在全面禁区内执行任务期间，英国皇家海军‘谢菲尔德’号（42型驱逐舰）今天下午晚些时候遭到一枚阿根廷导弹的攻击并被击中。”正是这种紧张感，那种绝对毫无情感的语调与想到有多少生命消逝之间的对比，正如我所说，我认为这绝对是我挥之不去的记忆之一。
that, as I say, I think is certainly one of the, it's certainly one of my overriding memories. Yeah, he became a real, do you know the weird thing? He became this huge public figure because of his incredibly slow and lugubrious delivery of this either good or bad news. And he had, a woman started stalking him. Well, I get, so all the men, all the men involved in this, they all wear kind of thick glasses, greying hair, balding, very unfashionable suits. And the idea that any of them could be sex symbols seems improbable. But he was one of the most improbable.
是的，他成了一个真正的——你知道最怪异的是什么吗？由于他以极其缓慢和阴郁的语调播报这些或好或坏的消息，他成了一个巨大的公众人物。甚至有一个女人开始跟踪他。好吧，我发现——所有参与其中的男士，所有这些男士，都戴着厚厚的眼镜，头发灰白、谢顶，穿着非常不合时装的西装。他们任何一个人能成为性感象征似乎都是不可思议的。但他却是最不可思议的一个。
He had to get the security men of the Ministry of Defence to protect him from this woman for whom he was obsessed with him. I mean, it does seem absolutely bizarre that he was announcing ship losses. But yeah, so the Sheffield... So what's the impact of that? Well, 20 men were lost on the Sheffield out of a crew of about almost 300, I think. So it's, you know... And then there's another HMS Coventry, isn't there? Later on, exactly.
他不得不让国防部的保安人员保护他，免受一个对她迷恋至极的女性的骚扰。我的意思是，他当时是在宣布军舰损失，这听起来确实极其荒谬。不过，是的，所以“谢菲尔德”号……那么这带来的影响是什么呢？“谢菲尔德”号上有20名船员丧生，船员总数大约近300人，我想。所以，你知道的……然后还有另一艘，“考文垂”号，对吧？后来的事，完全是这样。
So it's not comparable with the Bolognano. But of course, it's a massive... It's a tragedy for those people who do die in their families. The casualty figures are never released immediately, so they always appear at first to be more than they are. And I think it makes a huge dent in – it doesn't dent public opinion, but there's a sense of loss. It's really interesting how human life is much dearer in 1982 than it was
所以这无法与“贝尔格拉诺”号相比。但当然，这是一个巨大的——对那些牺牲的人及其家庭来说是一场悲剧。伤亡数字从来没有立即公布，所以一开始它们总是显得比实际情况要多。我认为这给公众舆论带来了巨大的冲击——它并没有动摇公众舆论，但有一种失落感。非常有趣的是，在1982年，人命比比如说在20世纪40年代要宝贵得多。
let's say in the 1940s so by the standards of the second or in the vietnam war or well britain has not known anything about the vietnam war and human life is so much dearer in 1982 that losses that to previous generations would have seen i mean i don't want to say trivial but they'd have seemed slight by comparison i assume colossal proportions. I mean, really tragic proportions. There's no real television coverage. So Robert Harris says about this, it's the worst reported war since the Crimea, which is quite something. Takes three weeks for the film footage to get back from the South Atlantic.
所以按照二战或越南战争的标准，或者——好吧，英国对越南战争一无所知——在1982年，人命要宝贵得多，以至于对前几代人来说似乎是——我不想说微不足道，但相比之下似乎微乎其微的损失，在当时却达到了庞大的规模。我的意思是，真正称得上是悲剧的规模。当时几乎没有什么电视报道。所以罗伯特·哈里斯曾这样评价：这是自克里米亚战争以来报道最糟糕的一场战争，这可真够可以的。胶片素材从南大西洋运回来需要三个星期。
So it's all happening in some shadowy realm of the imagination almost. You don't even see still photos often of these things. And so, Dominic, does the loss of HMS Sheffield, how worrying is that for the British High Command? And does it in any way threaten? Because by this point, presumably, they're closing in on the Falklands themselves. They are closing in. I don't think it does threaten the success of the operation but the combination of the belgrano
所以这一切几乎都发生在想象中某种阴暗的领域里。你甚至经常连这些事件的静态照片都看不到。那么，多米尼克，“谢菲尔德”号的损失对英国最高指挥部来说有多令人担忧？它是否在任何程度上构成了威胁？因为到了这个时候，据推测，他们已经在逼近福克兰群岛本身了。他们正在逼近。我不认为这构成了对行动成功的威胁，但“贝尔格拉诺”号事件、
and the sheffield and the international kind of outcry lots of people are really shocked by so many people are being killed um means that the government feels pressure to particularly from the americans um to to to compromise so again we talked about it previously, what happens and which is never really talked about in retrospectives of Margaret Thatcher and the Falklands is that in the aftermath of the loss of the Sheffield, they again agreed to compromise. So now this Peru deal that she supposedly wanted to scupper
“谢菲尔德”号事件以及国际上的强烈抗议——许多人对如此多的人丧生感到震惊——意味着政府感受到了压力，特别是来自美国人的压力，要求妥协。所以再次回到我们之前讨论过的内容，在回顾玛格丽特·撒切尔和福克兰群岛的历史时从未真正被提及的是：在“谢菲尔德”号损失之后，他们再次同意妥协。所以现在这个秘鲁协议，就是她本想通过击沉“贝尔格拉诺”号来破坏的那个协议（这其实是个神话），但她接受了秘鲁协议。所以在5月5日，内阁同意了——尽管他们实际上有分歧，但她是决定性的声音，她说我们应该接受这个协议。这个协议基本上和以前的旧协议一样，只是略作修改：
by sinking the belgrano which is a myth but she accepts the peru deal so on the 5th of may the cabinet agree that they're actually divided but she is the decisive voice and she says we should take the deal and the deal basically is the same old deal as before just just fiddled with which is both the british and the argentines will withdraw and the there will be a sort of a UN administration or an administration of different countries while the sovereignty of the islands is decided, which almost certainly means that they will end up
英国和阿根廷都将撤军，并在决定岛屿主权期间设立一个联合国或由不同国家组成的管理机构，这几乎可以肯定意味着它们最终将
under Argentine sovereignty. And she accepts the deal. And yet again, the Argentines are off the hook. Galtieri says no. He's just not prepared to withdraw his troops. And how long is this before the British actually reach the Falklands? So this is about two weeks. So this is the 5th of May or so.
归入阿根廷的主权之下。她接受了这个协议。然而，阿根廷人再次错失了脱身的机会。加尔铁里拒绝了。他根本不愿意撤军。那么这距离英国人真正抵达福克兰群岛还有多久？所以大约是两周时间。所以大约是5月5日左右。
And when that happens, is that it? No. Even then, it's not it, Tom. So there's then two more weeks of the fleet sailing. They're now virtually at the edge of the total exclusion zone so they're just a couple of hundred miles from the Falkland Islands and on the 16th of May the government makes a final offer to the Argentine government it's pretty much the same deal with a UN administration taking um coming in to run
当这种情况发生时，就结束了吗？没有。即便如此，也还没结束，汤姆。接下来舰队又航行了两周。他们现在实际上已经到了全面禁区的边缘，距离福克兰群岛只有几百英里了。在5月16日，英国政府向阿根廷政府提出了最后通牒，基本上还是同样的协议，由联合国管理机构接管
the Falklands now here's an extraordinary thing they they agreed the final offer and mrs thatcher's un ambassador actually says to her are you sure you want to send that offer because that's giving up quite a lot that's that will probably end up with argentina getting sovereignty of the islands at the end and she says yep i do want to send the offer they send the offer and the Argentines are given until the 18th, I think it is, or the 19th of May to accept it. The deadline expires. They have not accepted it.
福克兰群岛的运作。这里有一个非同寻常的事情：他们同意了最后通牒，撒切尔夫人的联合国大使甚至对她说：“你确定要发出这个提议吗？因为这等于放弃了相当多的东西，这最后很可能会导致阿根廷获得岛屿的主权。”她说：“是的，我就是要发出这个提议。”他们发出了提议，并且给予阿根廷人直到5月18日，我想是的，或者是5月19日来接受它。最后期限到了。他们没有接受。
So at that point, they basically give the go-ahead, go for the landing. So the fleet have sailed on and on. They are very close now. And you have this incredibly dramatic sort of D-Day style landing scenario. Well, hold on, Dominic. Hold on, hold on, hold on. This is, I mean, this is too dramatic a moment. I'm going to have a break. You love a cliffhanger.
所以在那个时候，他们基本上开了绿灯，决定进行登陆。因此舰队继续航行。他们现在非常近了。然后你就会看到这种极其戏剧性的、诺曼底登陆风格的登陆场景。等等，多米尼克。等等，等等，等等。这——这时刻太戏剧化了。我要休息一下。你真喜欢悬念。
So let's go and listen to some adverts, unless you're a member of the Restless History Club, in which case you won't have to listen to adverts. And when we come back. They're on the islands already in the Restless History Club, in which case you won't have to listen to adverts. And when we come back... They're on the islands already, in the Restless History Club. They've already, yeah, the Union Jack has already been run up over Port Stanley.
所以我们去听几个广告吧，除非你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的会员，那样的话你就不用听广告了。当我们回来时……他们已经在岛上了，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的会员，你就不用听广告了。当我们回来时……他们已经在岛上了，在“历史的其余部分”俱乐部里。他们已经——是的，米字旗已经在斯坦利港上空升起了。
Spoiler. When we come back, let's listen to what happens when the British actually land on the soil of the Falklands. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment.
剧透。当我们回来时，让我们听听当英国人真正踏上福克兰群岛土地时发生了什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com hello before we return to the falklands war we just wanted to talk about um another article that has recently gone up on the web page of our friends at unheard that is un h e r d unheard.com dominic yes um and this is uh well actually you know it's it's an article that does relate to the history of modern britain um it's an article about cumbernauld which is a new
这是您每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、以及一点八卦八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目和提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，在回到福克兰群岛战争之前，我们只想聊聊……我们朋友网站“UnHerd”上最近发布的一篇文章，网址是 un-h-e-r-d 点 com，unheard.com。多米尼克，是的……呃，这其实是一篇……你知道的，这确实是一篇与现代英国历史有关的文章。
town wasn't it that was built in the 60s in kind of very concrete what would now be called brutalist style it was brutalist so it's in north lanarkshire in scot Cumbernauld. It was put up, the city centre was put up in 1967, I think. It's an absolute sort of temple to 60s idealism and then the collapse of that idealism in the 1970s when it started rotting and there was all problems with damp and graffiti and crime and stuff. And I believe the article is by a guy called Daniel Calder and he's talking about the destruction of this dream and the fact that the buildings are about to be destroyed aren't
这是一篇关于坎伯诺尔的文章，这是一座新城镇，不是吗？建于20世纪60年代，采用现在被称为粗野主义风格的纯混凝土建筑。它是粗野主义的，位于苏格兰的北拉纳克郡。坎伯诺尔。它的市中心建于1967年，我想。这简直是60年代理想主义的圣殿，但在20世纪70年代这种理想主义破灭了，当时它开始腐烂，出现了潮湿、涂鸦和犯罪等各种问题。我相信这篇文章是由一个叫丹尼尔·卡尔德的人写的，他在谈论这个梦想的破灭，以及这些建筑即将被摧毁的事实，
they and architectural historians are very agitated about this yes they are although i gather that people who actually live there are less agitated delighted and i gather that daniel calder actually spent time in the soviet union perhaps you know his experience isn't entirely confined to scotland when writing about brutalist or should i tell you what tell you what he writes, Tom? Yeah, tell us. He says, glimpses of Cumbernauld's town centre from the window of the bus over the years have not done justice to the scale of the architectural catastrophe. It reminded me of the vast Ishmash plant in Odmurtia, Russia,
建筑历史学家对此感到非常焦虑，对吧？是的，他们是的。不过我听说真正住在那里的人没那么焦虑，反而很高兴。而且我听说丹尼尔·卡尔德曾在苏联待过，也许你知道，他在写粗野主义时，其经历并不仅仅局限于苏格兰。或者，我该告诉你他写了什么吗，汤姆？是的，告诉我们吧。他说：
where they pump out AK-47s and other weapons. But Ishmash at least had a decorative historical entrance. With the general absence of windows and the abundance of pipes and wires in Cumbernauld's town centre centre everything looks like the back of something um and of course it's interesting because a lot of people are now very very nostalgic in a way about brutalist architecture they see it as a lost utopianism I absolutely hate it personally entirely happy to see it the trouble is I think I quite like it existing but I wouldn't live in it I go the full Prince Charles on this.
“这些年来，透过巴士车窗对坎伯诺尔市中心的惊鸿一瞥，并未能公正地反映出这场建筑灾难的规模。它让我想起了俄罗斯乌德穆尔特的大型伊什马什工厂，那里大批量生产AK-47和其他武器。但伊什马什至少还有一个装饰性的历史大门。由于坎伯诺尔市中心普遍缺乏窗户，且管道和电线堆积如山，一切看起来都像某个东西的背面。”当然，这很有意思，因为现在很多人对粗野主义建筑怀有一种非常非常怀旧的情绪，他们将其视为一种失落的乌托邦主义。我个人绝对讨厌它，如果它被拆掉我完全双手赞成。麻烦在于，我觉得我其实挺喜欢它存在的，但我自己可不住在里面。在这点上我完全效仿查尔斯王子。
Yeah, I was about to say that. You know, a bit of columns, pediments, that kind of thing. Georgian. Yeah, Georgian. Prince Charles is all about Georgian. Yeah. But architectural historians and stuff would say, Tom, this is gross reactionary conservatism on your part.
是的，我正要这么说。你知道的，来点柱子、三角楣饰，诸如此类的东西。格鲁吉亚风格。是的，格鲁吉亚风格。查尔斯王子就是格鲁吉亚风格的死忠粉。是的。但建筑历史学家之流会说，汤姆，这是你极其反动的保守主义表现。
I don't care. And you're all about hierarchy and order and keeping the, you know, you don't care about social democratic idealism. But I worry that in saying that I'm not pushing it back against herd mentality which is what i'm all about because i suspect that most people probably agree with me unless they were in architecture departments i mean i'm aware you know it's a wholly unoriginal perspective anyway it's a fabulous article um do read it and you can read a lot else as well on their site we've got a special offer uh which is open to you the rest is history listener it's one
我才不在乎呢。你满脑子都是等级制度、秩序，还有保持——你知道的，你根本不在乎社会民主主义的理想主义。但我担心，这样说是在迎合某种群体思维，而这正是我极力反对的，因为我猜大多数人可能都同意我的看法，除非他们是建筑系的。我的意思是，我知道，你知道，这是一个完全缺乏原创性的观点。无论如何，这是一篇极好的文章——一定要去读读，你还可以在他们的网站上读到很多其他内容。我们有一个特别优惠，
pound a week normally but if you sign up for your first 10 weeks you get it free and you'll get four long pieces a day you'll get a podcast a podcast and youtube interviews showcasing new and independent thinking come on over yeah it says here unheard.com slash rest go and subscribe then come back to us and we'll continue with the second half of our own tremendous podcast thank you hello welcome back to the restless history Falklands war special and Dominic Sandbrook we have reached the climactic point the task force has steamed all its way from southern England down to the falklands and we
向你们开放，《历史的其余部分》的听众们。正常情况下是一英镑一周，但如果你注册前10周，就可以免费获得，并且你每天会获得四篇长文、一个播客、一个播客加YouTube采访，展示新的独立思维。快来吧！是的，这里写着 unheard.com/rest，快去订阅，然后回来继续我们自己精彩播客的下半部分。谢谢！大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》福克兰群岛战争特辑。我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。我们已经迎来了高潮时刻，特遣舰队已经一路从英格兰南部航行到了福克兰群岛，我们……
have reached the point where british troops land on the falklands so what happens next well tom there are some brilliant uh there's lots of really good falkland soldiers memoirs i think two of the best by ken lukowiak and vincent bramley i think we're both paratroopers really good um and uh vincent bramley has a wonderful description of the platoon commander calling all the NCOs together. They've sailed into the total exclusion zone. It's all been hijinks on the ships till now. It's been sunbathing. Giant page three.
英国军队在福克兰群岛登陆，接下来会发生什么呢？汤姆，有一些非常精彩的——有很多非常棒的关于福克兰群岛士兵的回忆录，我认为其中最好的两本是肯·卢科维亚克和文森特·布拉姆利写的，我觉得他们两个都是伞兵，真的非常棒。文森特·布拉姆利对排长召集所有士官开会的情景有非常精彩的描述。他们已经驶入全面禁区。到目前为止，在船上的一切都像是恶作剧。大家都在晒日光浴，还有巨大的第三版女郎。
Giant page threes. It's been a great laugh, basically. And now the platoon commanders say, right, this is it. And the mood completely changes. It's very tense. He says, you know, they can feel the fear. They can feel it in their stomachs. These are young men, by and large, who've never envisaged.
巨大的第三版女郎。基本上就是笑料不断。现在排长说，好了，就是这样。然后气氛彻底变了。非常紧张。他说，你知道的，他们能感受到恐惧。他们能从胃里感受到这种恐惧。这些大体上都是从未想象过这种场景的年轻小伙子们。
I mean, they're not conscripts. They're professional soldiers. But they've never really envisaged that this is anything like this. And also an amphibious landing, famously very difficult. You know, jumping off basically into the unknown wading up the beach it's very d-day um but it's colder right but it's yes because d-day is in the summer so but it's terrifying first they have to get off the canberra which is the big kind of cruise ship they have to get onto the assault ship intrepid which they do and and he has this great description that it's
我的意思是，他们不是义务兵。他们是职业军人。但他们从未真正想象过这会是这种场面。而且两栖登陆出了名的困难。你知道，基本上就是从船上跳进未知的海里，涉水走上海滩，这非常像诺曼底登陆，但更冷，对吧？是的，因为诺曼底登陆是在夏天，但这太吓人了。首先他们必须离开堪培拉号，也就是那艘大型游轮，他们必须换乘突击舰无畏号，他们确实这么做了，而且他有一个非常棒的描述，那就是……
dead you know the joking is over so and so where are they going to land so we've never really talked madly about the geography of the falkland islands there are two islands west falkland and east falkland um everything all the action is really on east falkland um so stanley is on east falkland but stanley's over on the east they know that the argentine forces thousands of them are in basically in stanley they're going to land on the other side um in a bay called San Carlos. They're almost a bit like kind of tiny fjords, I suppose, kind of low level fjords. I mean, that's probably geographically completely the wrong expression, but you kind of know what I mean. They're going to land there. They're going to land at night. They've got to hope that the Argentines don't
死一般的寂静，你知道，玩笑结束了。那么，他们究竟要在哪里登陆呢？所以我们其实从未疯狂讨论过福克兰群岛的地理情况。这里有两个岛，西福克兰和东福克兰。所有的行动实际上都在东福克兰。斯坦利就在东福克兰，但斯坦利在东海岸。他们知道阿根廷军队，数以千计的阿根廷军队，基本上都在斯坦利。他们要在另一侧登陆，在一个叫圣卡洛斯的海湾。它们有点像微型峡湾，我想，某种低洼的峡湾。我的意思是，从地理上讲这可能是完全错误的表达，但你大概明白我的意思。他们要在那里的夜间登陆。他们必须祈祷阿根廷人不会……
know exactly where they're going to land because they'll be sitting ducks. They'll just be sitting there unloading all the troops. So midnight on the 20th 21st of may they're kind of in position they get the they get the the go ahead they all go down they're waiting um they're waiting for like they're packed in they're waiting for this kind of green light to come on um the green light finally comes on they all get into their little landing craft then they're kind of bobbing um through this freezing sort of sea towards the land they can see tracer fire up above them you know they're they're so nervous they're they're complete sitting ducks but they get there they haven't been attacked and then they're off their
准确知道他们要在哪里登陆，因为那样他们就会成为活靶子。他们就会毫无防备地站在那里卸载所有部队。所以在5月20日到21日的午夜，他们已经就位了，他们得到了批准，所有人都下去了，他们排着队等待着，等待着绿灯亮起。绿灯终于亮了，大家都上了各自的小型登陆艇，然后他们在一片冰冷的海面上向陆地颠簸前行，他们能看到头顶上的曳光弹。你知道，他们太紧张了，他们完全就是活靶子，但他们到达了，没有遭到攻击，然后他们……
ramps go down they're up they're on the beach and amazingly um the argentines have not cottoned on to the fact they're there and will not for a few hours. That's very poor. Well, it is poor, but I mean, it's also a result for the British. Yeah, it is. But I mean, you know that there's a landing coming. Yeah, but they don't know where. They don't know where. They've got helicopters.
跳板放下了，他们上去了，踏上了海滩，令人惊奇的是，阿根廷人根本没有察觉到他们已经到了，并且在几个小时内都不会发现。这太糟糕了。好吧，确实很糟糕，但我的意思是，这也是英国方面的一个成果。是的，确实是。但我的意思是，你知道登陆就要来了。是的，但他们不知道在哪里。他们不知道在哪里。他们有直升机。
They have got stuff. Kind of buzzing around. Yeah, but it's the dead of night. What have got lights? Torches. Well, you should go on your brother's podcast They've got, yeah, but it's the dead of night. What got light? Tortures. Well, you should go on your brother's podcast and he will explain the military, the logistics, which I can't really do.
他们有各种装备。到处嗡嗡作响。是的，但这是深夜。哪来的光？火把？好吧，你应该去你兄弟的播客……他们有，是的，但这是深夜。哪来的光？火把？好吧，你应该去你兄弟的播客，他会向你解释军事和后勤，这我可真做不到。
But anyway, they get off. I mean, there's wonderful stories. The task force have journalists embedded with them. So most famously, Max Hastings, and this is what makes his name, basically. So a lot of our listeners will know as a historian, but before that was a newspaper editor, and before that was this correspondent
但无论如何，他们上岸了。我的意思是，有很多精彩的故事。特遣部队嵌入了记者。最著名的是马克斯·海斯廷斯，这也是他成名的地方。所以我们的很多听众都知道他是一位历史学家，但在那之前他是一位报纸编辑，再之前他是这位战地记者。
who really became the voice and became the pen of the Falklands campaign. They've landed, and there's this tiny hamlet called San Carlos, and the Royal Marines go to the farmhouse, and the bloke who opens the door to them says, you're British, we've been expecting you for two or three nights. And his wife says, we were getting fed up of waiting for you.
他真正成为了福克兰群岛战役的声音和笔杆子。他们登陆了，有一个叫圣卡洛斯的极其偏远的小村庄，皇家海军陆战队去了那里的农舍，开门的那家伙对他们说：“你们是英国人，我们已经盼了两三天了。”他的妻子说：“我们都快等烦了。”
A guy from the Sunday Times with another attachment, they get to a farm guy's cottage, and he opens the door, and he offers them some soup. And the first thing he says is, did Leeds United get relegated? So it's very sort of, that's the 1950s kind of comedy. Sort of evening wisdom. Exactly, aspect to it. So there they are.
一个来自《星期日泰晤士报》的记者跟着另一支分队，他们找到了一个农夫的村舍，农夫打开了门，给他们端了一些汤。他说的第一句话是：“利兹联队降级了吗？”所以这非常有一种——那是20世纪50年代的喜剧风格。那种久经世故的智慧。没错，就是这方面的感觉。所以他们就在那里。
They've landed without the loss of a single man. But basically by daylight, the Argentines know they're there. So they send in their fighters. They immediately hit two ships. That's Argonaut and Antrim. So lives are now being lost and basically there's now a race to unload all the equipment get all the stuff off because there's no like great supply line back to london they brought all their stuff with them and if it's
他们登陆时没有损失一个人。但基本上到了白天，阿根廷人就知道他们来了。于是他们派出了战斗机。他们立刻击中了两艘船。那是“阿尔戈诺次”号和“安特里姆”号。因此生命开始消逝，基本上现在是一场争分夺秒的卸载所有装备、把所有东西都搬下来的竞赛，因为这里没有通往伦敦的宏大补给线，他们把所有的东西都随身带来了，如果这些东西被……
destroyed destroyed yeah right but they managed to get all the stuff off it's at this point that coventry you mentioned commentary Coventry earlier on, it's a type 42 destroyer like Sheffield, that that is hit. 19 men are killed on Coventry. Most of them get off. By the 27th, which is basically six days, they've managed to unload all their stuff.
摧毁了，那就全毁了，对吧？不过他们设法把所有东西都卸了下来。正是在这个时候，你刚才提到的考文垂号，考文垂号，它是一艘像谢菲尔德号一样的42型驱逐舰，被击中了。19人在考文垂号上丧生。大多数人撤离了。到27号，也就是基本上六天后，他们设法卸下了所有的物资。
So they've unloaded 3,000 men and all their gear, all their ammunition, their vehicles, whatever they need, and off they go. So now you're into a completely different phase of the campaign, which is the kind of land campaign. And at this point, you know, the government's just going to go for it. There's going to be no more talk of peace talks. Once they've got the men on the islands and lives are being lost, they're just going to do it.
所以他们卸下了3000名士兵以及他们所有的装备、所有的弹药、他们的车辆、他们需要的一切，然后他们出发了。所以现在你进入了战役的一个完全不同的阶段，也就是地面战阶段。在这个时候，你知道，政府打算放手大干了。将不再有关于和平谈判的讨论。一旦他们把士兵送上岛屿，生命正在消逝，他们就要大干一场了。
And the first sort of battle, I mean, I say battle, they're obviously not Second do it and the first sort of battle i mean i say battle they're obviously not second world war type battles they're much smaller but they're still very bloody and vicious and almost because they're smaller they're often hand to hand at times which makes them you know there's a sort of intensity to them so the first thing they do is they actually turn some of them turn slightly back on themselves away from port stanley to a place called goose green which is on an isthmus, which connects the two harbs of East Falkland. And the reason they do that is the Argentines have a kind of garrison
第一场战斗，我的意思是战斗，它们显然不是第二次世界大战那种类型的战斗，它们规模要小得多，但仍然非常血腥和残酷，而且几乎因为规模更小，有时往往是肉搏战，这使得它们，你知道的，有一种紧张感。所以他们做的第一件事，实际上是将一部分人稍微调回原地，远离阿斯托·斯坦利，去一个叫鹅卵滩（Goose Green）的地方，它位于连接东福克兰两个海岬的地峡上。他们这么做的原因是阿根廷人在那里有一个驻军……
of 1,000 men there, and the British government say, you have to knock that out because we need an early land success. And even though the commander doesn't really want to do it, Julian Thompson is told, you have to do it because we need a land victory immediately. We're not just going to leave this garrison there. You've got to basically eliminate it. This is where you get the real martyr.
有1000人，英国政府说，你们必须把它端掉，因为我们需要一场早期的地面胜利。尽管指挥官并不是很想这么做，朱利安·汤普森被告知，你必须这么做，因为我们需要立即取得地面胜利。我们不能只是把这支驻军留在那儿。你基本上必须消灭他们。这就是你看到真正殉道者的地方。
So this is Colonel H. Jones. Colonel H. Jones, old Etonian, who is the commanding officer of 2 Para, who's always had a reputation for sort of devil-may-care kind of recklessness. And he leads his men on this it was planned as a raid but he basically wants it to be a big battle and he leads them um they start fighting starts at two in the morning on the 28th of may they get basically bogged down and stuff and he decides he's going to do a bit of a henry the fifth he just charges up the hill and just charge up yeah lead the charge and he's shot down and killed but britain ends up winning the british end up winning the battle of goose green and is that because of the his his charge does
这就是H·琼斯中校。H·琼斯中校，老伊顿公学毕业生，2伞兵团的指挥官，一直以来都有那种天不怕地不怕的鲁莽名声。他率领部下进行这场战斗——原本计划只是一场突袭，但他基本上希望它变成一场大战，他率领部下……战斗于5月28日凌晨两点开始，他们基本上陷入了泥潭等困境，他决定要来一次亨利五世式的壮举，他直接冲上山坡发起冲锋，就这样冲锋，然后他被枪击身亡，但英国人最终赢得了鹅卵滩战役。是因为他的冲锋才……
that no they'd have won anyway they'd have won anyway so there's always been a bit of a debate among military historians about um was this a need need needless yeah i mean i'm not a military historian as some people people are military stories listening to this will probably know so people are often arguing in the about the minutiae of these attacks rather like you know sports reporters would argue about a scrum or something or yeah a penalty yeah the the but also there there's never a sort of definitive account because there's always battles are so confusing so there's always sort of but you said the truth that the british needed um a victory did they also need a war hero i mean do you think we didn't need one but they were happy to have one so the press immediately
不是的，他们无论如何都会赢的。他们无论如何都会赢的。所以军事历史学家之间一直存在一些争辩，关于这是否是一次不必要的行动——是的，我的意思是，我不是军事历史学家，正如听这个节目的某些人所知，所以人们经常在争论这些攻击的细节，就像体育记者会争论一次争球或点球之类的事情。但是，也没有一个绝对权威的解释，因为战斗总是如此混乱，所以总是有各种看法。但你刚才说英国人需要一场胜利，他们是否也需要一个战争英雄？我的意思是，你认为我们并不是非要不可，但他们很高兴能有一个？所以媒体立刻……
he's got a wife i mean they couldn't so they couldn't say well i mean it's just kind of insane incompetence no but i don't think i don't think i think it would be very harsh and unfair to say it was well some people have said that, haven't they? Yeah, you're right. Okay, fair enough. They have. Some people have. You're absolutely right.
他有一个妻子，我的意思是，他们不能说——所以他们不能说，好吧，这只是一种疯狂的无能。不，但我不认为，我不认为，我觉得说这是一场——这会非常严厉且不公平。不过有些人确实这么说过，不是吗？是的，你说的对。好吧，好吧。他们确实说过。你完全正确。
The press immediately, they turn his widow into a great Sarah or Sarah Jones. They turn her into this great martyr. She's a sort of photogenic widow with young children, I think. So absolutely, yes. He becomes the face of the fallen, if you like. And everyone needs heroes. Exactly. So what's that? That's about 28th of May.
媒体立刻把他的遗孀塑造成了一位伟大的萨拉，或者说萨拉·琼斯。他们把她塑造成了一位伟大的殉道者。她是一个上镜的年轻遗孀，我想还有年幼的孩子。所以完全正确，是的。如果你愿意的话，他成了阵亡将士的面孔。每个人都需要英雄。完全正确。那么，那是什么时候？大约是5月28日。
Then there was one last attempt to give a piece. Back to the comedy. Very good. So this is from Ronald Reagan. He rings Mrs. Thatcher. We have a transcript of the call. It's very funny. She's absolutely –
然后是最后一次争取和平的尝试。回到喜剧。非常棒。所以这是罗纳德·里根打给撒切尔夫人的电话。我们有通话记录。非常有趣。她绝对是——
No, no, no. Ronald, no. I didn't lose some of my finest ships and my finest lives to leave quietly under a ceasefire without the Argentines withdrawing. Just suppose Alaska was invaded. It's a long way away from you. Put all your people up there to retake it. You wouldn't withdraw.
不，不，不。罗纳德，不。我没有失去我最优秀的几艘军舰和我最优秀的生命，来换取在阿根廷人撤军之前悄悄地在停火协议下离开。假设阿拉斯加被侵略了。那离你很远。把你所有的人都派到那里去夺回它。你才不会撤退呢。
You wouldn't do it. And Reagan, if you read the transcript, he starts off talking quite a lot. And then when he gets to about page two, he's like, Margaret, I... Margaret, and at the end, he just says, well, Margaret, I know I've intruded. And then, sorry, that almost veered into my Donald Trump, which it shouldn't have done.
你不会这么做的。如果你读一下通话记录，里根一开始说了很多。然后当翻到大约第二页时，他就像是在说：“玛格丽特，我……玛格丽特，”最后他说：“好吧，玛格丽特，我知道我打扰了。”然后，抱歉，这差点变成我的唐纳德·特朗普腔调，不应该这样的。
But anyway, she says, oh, no, you haven't intruded at all, Ron. You know how you'd feel if you went through the same conflict. And off he goes with his tail between his legs that she's not going to compromise now. And to be fair to that, the British have made a lot of attempts to compromise but the argentines were having none of it so the argentine there's this poor bloke called mario ben ramine menendez who's that guy who's been put in is he he's arabic is he i imagine he's got moorish antecedents time maybe maybe. Hence the pronunciation. Exactly. I look at him and I see multicultural heritage. He's part of that extraordinary mix that you get in the medieval period in Spain.
但无论怎样，她说：“哦，不，你一点也没打扰，罗恩。你知道如果你经历同样的冲突，你会作何感想。”然后他夹着尾巴灰溜溜地走了，因为她现在是绝不会妥协的。公平地说，英国人曾多次试图妥协，但阿根廷人根本不买账。所以阿根廷那边有一个可怜的家伙叫马里奥·本哈明·梅嫩德斯，就是那个被派去的人，他是阿拉伯人吗？我猜他有摩尔人的血统，也许吧，也许吧。因此连发音都这样。完全正确。我看着他，仿佛看到了多元文化的遗产。他是中世纪西班牙那种非凡大融合的一部分。
Philosophy, bubbling fountains, the Alhambra, all that. Anyway, he's pitched up in Stanley and he basically says to General Galtieri, we are sunk, we are finished, unless you can send support general galtieri says you know no support is coming you must hold out and then there's publishers i have to say an absolutely splendid call to arms the adversary is getting ready to attack puerto argentino which is what they call poor stanley with a rash and hateful intention of conquering the capital of the Malvinas not only must we beat them we must do it in such a way that their defeat is so crushing
哲学、喷涌的喷泉、阿尔罕布拉宫，诸如此类。不管怎样，他来到了斯坦利，基本上对加尔铁里将军说：“我们沉了，我们完了，除非你能派支援。”加尔铁里将军说，你知道的，没有支援会来，你们必须坚守。然后有——我必须说，这是一次极其精彩的战斗动员令：“敌方正准备以轻率而可恨的意图进攻波多阿根廷诺（他们这样称呼斯坦利港），企图征服马尔维纳斯的首都。我们不仅要击败他们，而且必须以这样一种方式击败他们，即他们的失败是如此彻底……
that they will never again have the impertinence to invade our land to arms to battle it's very kind of Aragon yes yeah it is and does it have the desired effect it doesn't no it's the Argentine soldiers are incredibly miserable many of them by this point have actually said, they write in letters and diaries or memoirs. They say basically by this point, we're desperate for the British to arrive so that we can go home. They're really cold. They're really miserable.
以至于他们再也没有狂妄自大到敢入侵我们的土地。拿起武器，投入战斗。”这有点阿拉贡的风格，对吧？是的，确实是。那它达到了预期的效果吗？并没有，不。阿根廷士兵感到无比痛苦，到这个时候，许多人实际上已经说过了，他们在信件、日记或回忆录中写道。他们基本上说，到了这个时候，我们迫切希望英国人到来，这样我们就能回家了。他们真的很冷。他们真的很痛苦。
They don't have enough rations. They hate their officers who treat them like dirt. So their morale is pretty low. So you have a couple more, one more tragedy for the british which is landing more troops um a place called bluff cove which is oh is that is that the galahad so this is the galahad simon weston simon weston who is the other great british war hero who suffers burns to 46 percent of his body, is very, very badly hurt, loses eyelids and his ears and stuff like this, but survives
他们没有足够的口粮。他们讨厌把他们当狗一样对待的军官。所以他们的士气相当低落。所以还有另外几起——对英国人来说还有一次悲剧，那就是运送更多的部队去一个叫 Bluff Cove 的地方，哦，那是……那是加拉赫号吗？所以这就是加拉赫号事件，西蒙·韦斯顿，西蒙·韦斯顿是另一位伟大的英国战争英雄，他的全身46%被烧伤，伤势非常非常严重，失去了眼睑和耳朵之类的器官，但活了下来……
and then becomes the face of kind of heroism. So 49 men are killed there. But, I mean, by this point, it's pretty obvious. The British are a professional army, incredibly well-trained, very well-armed, got all the right equipment, absolutely poised for this. This is what they've been preparing for. The Argentines are conscripts.
然后成为了某种英雄主义的面孔。49人在那里丧生。但是，我的意思是，到了这个时候，已经相当明显了。英国军队是一支职业军队，训练极其有素，武装精良，拥有所有正确的装备，为这一切做好了充分准备。这就是他们一直在准备的。阿根廷人是义务兵。
There's only really going to be one winner. The British troops are poised around Stanley. So Stanley is, I mean, they're described as kind of mount this, mount that, but they're not really mountains. They're kind of hills. I mean, they're not kind of the Alps or something. So these hills at Mount London, Mount Harriet, and there's one called Two Sisters, which're not kind of the alps or something um so these hills at mount longdon mount harriet and there's one called two sisters which is two kind of peaks and basically what the
基本上只会有一个赢家。英国军队在斯坦利周围就位。所以斯坦利是——我的意思是，它们被描述为爬上这个，爬上那个，但它们实际上并不是山。它们有点像丘陵。我的意思是，它们不像是阿尔卑斯山之类的地方。所以这些山丘是朗登山（Mount Longdon）、哈里特山（Mount Harriet），还有一座叫“两姐妹”（Two Sisters）的山……所以这些山丘是朗登山、哈里特山，还有一座叫“两姐妹”的山，它有两个山峰。基本上……
british are going to have to do is just attack um usually uh very late at night or first thing in the morning sort of in the early hours um so it's kind of night fighting which is always really confused and horrible and it's kind of close quarters basically work their way up these slopes clean out the argentine trenches and positions at the top and and you know all the accounts of this that you get from the i mean we haven't really dug into the kind of military side of it because it's not what we do but when you read the soldiers memoirs they are they're they are horrible they're really horrible so there's um i mean i can't quote everything um but for example in vincent bramley's um memoir there's a point where an army medic says to him i've done all the
英国人必须做的事情就是发起进攻。通常是在深夜或者清晨，也就是破晓前的时分，所以这是一种夜战，总是非常混乱和糟糕，基本上是近距离搏杀，沿着这些山坡向上推进，肃清顶部的阿根廷战壕和阵地，而且你知道，你从——我的意思是，我们并没有真正深入探讨军事层面，因为这不是我们的专长，但当你读到士兵的回忆录时，它们是——它们真的很糟糕。所以有——我的意思是，我无法引用所有内容，但例如在文森特·布拉姆利的回忆录中，有一个地方，一名陆军医护兵对他说，我已经为这进行了所有可能的训练，它仍然不是我想象的那样。因为没有什么能让他们对身边朋友中枪、脑浆迸裂做好准备。那么伤亡情况如何？
training possible for this and it still hasn't been what i thought it would be and these because nothing prepares them for their friends being shot around them people's brains falling so what are the casualties well they're not massive so they're they're sort of dozens um sometimes just a handful of people certainly the british side because the british they're like a clockwork machine sort of working perfectly so the casualties aren't great so for example in longden the british lose um 23 men on two sisters they lose eight on mount harriet they lose seven so they're quite they're So they're not massive by any means. But again, there's something about the intimacy of it, I suppose,
好吧，伤亡并不巨大，大概是几十人，有时只有寥寥数人。当然是对英军而言，因为英军就像一台发条机器，完美地运转着，所以伤亡并不算大。例如在朗登山，英军阵亡了23人；在两姐妹山，阵亡了8人；在哈里特山，阵亡了7人。所以他们的伤亡其实相当……所以绝不算巨大。但同样地，我猜那种肉搏的亲密感，使得它看起来……你是否也觉得，福克兰群岛听起来非常像英国陆军训练的地形？比如苏格兰高地、布雷肯比肯斯山脉或达尔瓦尔之类的地方。也许，你知道的，你在那种训练中做过无数次，突然之间你真的身处其中——也许这种熟悉感反而让情况变得更糟了，我不知道。
that makes it seem... Do you think also, I mean, the Falklands sounds very like the kind of terrain on which the British Army train. So the Highlands or Brecon Beacons or Darwal or something like that. That perhaps, you know, you've done it so many times on that in that kind of training and suddenly you really are i mean maybe the fact it seems so familiar makes it almost worse i don't know yeah i can see what you mean the fact that it feels like an exercise but it's not and people are actually dropping down around you yeah i think there's some i mean it's an interesting i found this really interesting to study and to write
是的，我明白你的意思。那种感觉就像是一场演习，但又不是，人们真的在你周围倒下。是的，我认为这有一些——我的意思是，我觉得研究和书写这段历史非常有趣，因为我以前从未真正写过关于战争的文章。当你阅读士兵的回忆录时，他们谈论的一件事——有时会在特别偏向左翼的福克兰群岛媒体报道中出现——就是我们所谓的暴行。也就是说，用刺枪刺杀俘虏、割下耳朵。作为什么？作为战利品？作为战利品。在……中有一个片段，我不记得是谁的书了。我想可能是肯·卢科维亚克的书，他说，哦不，是文森特·布拉姆利的书。
about because i'd never really written about war. And when you read the soldiers' memoirs, one thing they talk about, which sometimes comes up in particularly in this sort of left-leaning press accounts of the Falklands, are what we would call atrocities. So that is bayoneting prisoners, cutting off the ears. As what? As trophies? As trophies. There's a bit in, I can't remember whose book it is. I think it might be Ken Lukowiak, where he says, oh no, it's Vincent Bramley.
他说他的一个朋友捡起了一个人的头颅，大脑还在里面，说：“哦，这是终极纪念品。我太太一定会喜欢这个。”我的意思是，这非常像帕奇阿内格（Petch-an-egg）的行为。这确实非常像帕奇阿内格的行为。但问题是，如果你真的读过任何关于以前战争的军事历史，真正详细的记录，这种事总是发生。我的意思是，这在第二次世界大战中发生过，在第一次世界大战中也发生过，但是……
He says one of his friends picks up a man's head with the brain still inside and says, oh, this is the ultimate souvenir. My missus will love this. I mean, that's very Petch-an-egg behaviour. It is very Petch-an-egg behaviour. But the thing is, if you actually read any military history about previous wars really detailed ones this always happened i mean this happened in world war ii it happened in world war one but
20世纪80年代的英国，除了北爱尔兰之外，自认为是一个已经超越了这一切的国家，这根本不是会发生的事情。但是，对这一现象进行过最有趣论述的历史学家是海伦·帕尔（Helen Parr），她的叔叔戴夫在伞兵团服役，我想他在福克兰群岛阵亡了。她谈到了所谓的暴行。她指出的一点是，以战争的标准来看，福克兰群岛其实很少发生重大的暴行。其中一个原因实际上是，由于这……
there's something britain in the 1980s with the exception of northern ireland felt itself to be a country that had gone beyond all this this just wasn't what happened but the historian who's written about this most interestingly is um a historian Helen Parr, whose uncle Dave was in the Paras, I think, and he was killed in the Falklands. And she talks about the sort of, you know, the so-called atrocities. And one of the things she points out is actually by the standards of wars, there were very few major atrocities in the Falklands. And one reason for that is that actually it's, as it were,
是一场更加堂堂正正的战役，双方实际上都不是为了自己的祖国而战。是的。所以他们几乎是在一个稍微中立的领土上作战，因为英国士兵对福克兰群岛没有什么巨大的利益攸关。我的意思是，那不是他们的家园。他们以前从未去过那里。当然，他们确实认为这是他们的，
a more gallant campaign, is that neither side is actually fighting for their own native land. Yeah. So they're almost fighting on a slightly neutral territory because the British soldiers have no great stake in the Falklands. I mean, it's not there. They've never been there before. They do think of it as theirs, of course,
他们对那里的人民有一种模糊的联系。但这与为你的家乡而战并不是同一回事。所以它没有那种高强度的仇恨。而且周围没有平民。我的意思是，平民，那1800名平民，都躲在农舍里喝茶、躲避战火。
and they feel some vague connection to the people who live there. But it's not the same thing as fighting for your hometown. So it doesn't have that intensity. And there's no civilians around. I mean, the civilians, the 1,800 civilians, are all kind of drinking tea and kind of hunkering down in their farmhouses.
所以从这个角度来看，我认为这并不是一场特别血腥的战役。不管怎样，基本上是两三晚的战斗，阿根廷人最终就崩溃了。他们投降了吗？他们正式投降了吗？他们最终投降了。所以你会看到……6月14日星期一的早晨，发生了惊人的一幕。他们刚刚打完仗，英国人继续前进。6月14日星期一的早晨。所以他们刚刚打完仗。英国人继续前进。苏格兰卫队打到了坦布尔当山（Mount Tumble Down）的山顶。
So I don't think it's a a it's not an especially bloody campaign from that point of view anyway um so it's basically three two three nights of fighting and the argentines just eventually kind of crumple do they surrender do they officially surrender they do eventually so you get to there's this amazing scene on the the 14th morning of the monday the 14th of june so they've just fought they've the british have moved on the 14th, the morning of the Monday, the 14th of June. So they've just fought. The British have moved on. The Scots Guards have fought to the top of Mount Tumble Down.
2伞兵团打到了无线电岭（Wireless Ridge）的山顶。所以现在他们基本上已经逼近斯坦利了。斯坦利，顺便说一下，我的意思是，它是首都，但它是一个极小的镇。按大多数标准来看，它是一个大村庄。是的，确实是一个大村庄，你知道的。按大多数标准来看，它是一个大村庄，是的，一个大村庄，你知道的，
And two para have got to the top of Wireless Ridge. So now they're basically closed in on Stanley. And Stanley, which is, by the way, I mean, it's the capital. But it's a tiny town. I mean, it's by the standards of most. A large village. Yes, a large village, you know, really. And it's by by by the standards of most a large village yes a large village you know really um and it's sort of laid out beneath them and and the most the famous thing that happens now is i talked about embedded reporters so one of them is the evening standards max hastings and he's with um he's on wireless ridge so he's with the paras and he sits down he writes his
它就铺展在他们下方。现在发生的最著名的事情是，我刚才提到过嵌入式记者。其中之一是《旗帜晚报》的马克斯·海斯廷斯，他和伞兵一起在无线电岭上。他坐下来，写下了他给《旗帜晚报》的最新战地报道，然后他抬头看了看斯坦利，他看到阿根廷人基本上正逃回镇里，他心想，我其实可以亲自下山去，我会成为第一个到那里的人。他搭乘了一辆伞兵的便车下山来到市郊，然后他们停下来煮茶。
latest dispatch to the evening standard and then he looks and he sees stan paras and he sits down and he writes his latest dispatch to the evening standard and then he looks and he sees stanley and he sees the argentines are kind of basically running back into the town and he thinks to himself you know i could actually just go down there and i would be the first person there and he hitches a lift with some paratroopers down the hill to the outskirts and then they stop to brew up some tea. And he just thinks, well, I'll just go. And he starts, it's an amazing scene in his memoirs. He starts walking and he just walks along this lane.
他心想，好吧，我就去吧。他开始——他的回忆录里有很精彩的一幕。他开始步行，沿着这条小路走。其中一个伞兵问：“你在干什么？”海斯廷斯根本不理他，继续往前走。他拐过一个弯，然后心想：“天哪，我居然真的到这儿了。”你知道当你进行了一次长途跋涉，尤其是当你下山看到你要走去的那个村庄，不知不觉你就到了那种感觉吗？是的，这正是发生的事情。他看到了一群阿根廷士兵，用西班牙语或英语对他们说“早上好”——我想是用英语。他们……
And one of the paras says, what are you doing? And Hastings just ignores him and keeps going. And he kind of goes around a corner and then he thinks, God, I'm kind of here. You know how it is when you've done a big walk, especially when you're walking downhill and you see the sort of village that you're walking to and within before you know it you're there yeah this is exactly what happens and he sees a group of argentine soldiers and he says to them good morning in spanish or english in english i think and they sort of um they sort of say nothing. They look very miserable.
他们什么也没说。他们看起来非常痛苦。最后他撞见了一个上校，海斯廷斯问：“你们打算投降吗？”上校说：“我想是的，但我得等你们的将军见了梅嫩德斯将军才知道。”海斯廷斯说：“哦，好吧，我能继续往前走吗？”上校说：“当然可以。”
And eventually he bumps into a colonel and Hastings says, are you planning to surrender? And the colonel says, I think so, but I won't know until your general meets General Menendez. And Hastings is like, oh, okay, can I keep going? And the colonel says, of course you can.
于是他继续往前走。这就是我们之前谈到的有趣的事情，阿根廷人总体上表现得相当不错，鉴于他们对自己人那种糟糕透顶的行为，我认为正如我们之前所说，他们在与他们羡慕并怨恨了这么久的英国人作战时，有一种必须表现得最好的一面的心理。所以他继续往前走，很多阿根廷人看到了他，但他们没有向他开枪或做什么，只是把视线移开或瞪着他之类的。他最后去了酒吧，叫“高地雁”（Upland Goose），有一个极其精彩的时刻，他走进去……
So he just keeps going. And this is the funny thing that we talked about earlier that the argentines generally were quite well behaved and given their abysmal behavior to their own people they were very i think as we said before they have this sort of sense they have to be on their best behavior when they're fighting the british who they've envied and you know resented for so long so he keeps going and lots of argentines see him but they don't shoot him or anything they just sort of look away or glare at him or whatever he ends up going to the pub it's called the upland goose and there's this incredible moment when he walks in
酒吧里有20个人，马克斯·海斯廷斯对他们说：“我是和英国特遣部队一起来的。”他们全都鼓起掌来。然后店老板对他说：“我们从未怀疑过英国人会来。我们一直在等待这一刻。现在，你想喝一杯吗？”他说：“是的。”他说：“是的。”好吧，我认为这是一个非常棒的结束语。
and there are 20 people in the bar of the pub and max hastings says to them um i'm with the british task force and they all start clapping and then the landlord says to them, I'm with the British task force. And they all start clapping. And then the landlord says to him, we never doubted for a moment that the British would come. We've just been waiting for the moment. Now, would you like a drink? And he says, yes. And he says, yes. Well, I think that's a splendid note on which to end.
我们还有最后一集。我们将回顾战争的余波。为什么它很重要？还是说它根本不重要？是的，它重要吗？我们有很多问题。所以我们将讨论其中一些问题，试图将我们所经历的叙事置于更广泛的背景中，
We have one last episode. We will look at the aftermath of the war. Why it mattered? Or did it matter? Yeah, did it matter? We have a lot of questions. So we'll go through some of those questions, trying to put the narrative that we've had in the kind of the broader context,
这场战争对阿根廷、对英国、对更广阔的世界产生的影响。我将提出我关于福克兰群岛与英国脱欧的论点。哇，那太令人兴奋了。确实很兴奋。桑德布鲁克论点。人们喜欢谈论英国脱欧，不是吗？
the impact that the war had on Argentina, on Britain, on the broader world. And I shall be advancing to my thesis about the Falklands and Brexit. Well, that's exciting. It is exciting. A Sandbrook thesis. And people love talking about Brexit, don't they?
他们太喜欢了。怎么也谈不够。是的，他们太喜欢了。所以我们周一见，继续我们的福克兰群岛系列的最后一部分。或者如果你现在就想听，加入“历史就是一切”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）即可收听那一集。www.restishistorypod.com。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史就是一切》。想要收听独家番外、抢先体验、无广告收听……
They love it. They can't get enough of it. Yeah, they love it. So we'll see you back on Monday for the final part of our Falklands series. Or if you want to listen to it right now, join the Rest Is History Club to get access to that episode. www.restishistorypod.com. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦花边。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想无广告收听、获取独家番外……
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
并优先购买现场活动门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
获取现场门票的早钟者访问权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。即 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目尚无评论。点击文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。